this is a big distinction everyone
thinks if you voted brexit because of
immigration they automatically think
you're ma we finally meet
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I wasn't particularly political
until brexit basically pulled me off the
bench
she watched David Cameron absolutely
wetting the bed and I just had to get
involved because I thought well if he's
not doing it right I have to and one
thing I would say however is because of
the mess that we're seeing it's telling
some people aren't turning some people
off some people think well the pathogens
are just doing such a bad job they're
not listening to us and some people
think well no they're doing such a bad
job we need to get involved and I agree
I think I think the problem that could
happen is that we have distrust in our
politicians because they're not actually
implementing the result of a democratic
vote and I think that's where the
distrust might come from actually
because people for the first time a lot
of people voted for the bracelet
referendum what sort of message it sends
out to then not implement that vote it's
scary and I worry because there is a lot
of distrust in our politicians already
so I think that could be the final nail
in the coffin
yeah I think there's been this massive
correlation between being a breaks a
tear and being far right I think that is
categorically not true if you voted
brexit because you are fed up with a
political system that has left your area
behind not a racist bone in your body
but unfortunately neither Faraj
expressly uses racism I don't agree I
think what Nyjah Faraj argues this is a
big distinction
everyone thinks if you voted brexit
because of immigration they
automatically think your motivation but
that's the main argument that Nigel
Rodgers presented it is about control
over that immigration
[Music]
I do I think in the first place I
shouldn't have been free movement but I
would say that I'm not even in terms of
I'm an anti-immigration I'm absolutely
not I'm Pro immigration I see the
benefits that we can reap from it and of
course the people have already come over
they absolutely deserve the right to
stay here but I think going on from this
we should have the ability to control
our borders unfortunately there was a
lot of well yeah I go with lies and from
2016 from NIDA Faraj citizens from other
EU countries make up 5% of our
population but they make up 10% of our
doctors which means immigration from EU
countries is literally keeping us alive
yes Wow
screw it sorry I'm breaking the rules
I'm staying right there the reason for
me is such a tough one is because I
don't know if the people that support
remain actually liberal I mean liberal
is all about freedom and the EU is sold
as a speaker of freedom freedom of
movement freedom of trade but the point
is it's a lie it's it's not the true
definition of freedom to me freedom is
about having control over your borders
having control of your fishing waters
and instead we're left shackled to the
EU and I don't think that is true
freedom unfortunately one of the biggest
divides in the country is been routine
rich and poor there's a North and South
divide which has left large areas of the
country behind now there are some people
who voted remain who are totally ok with
things as they are and they have a
completely out of touch with people in
working-class towns in the North in the
in the East and Norfolk a lot of people
like myself I've woken up through just
how angry people are across the country
just how much needs to change it's being
acknowledged that's why they're so
frustrated the anger was long before the
referendum
[Music]
nice Donald Trump he's the guy that says
that most Mexican immigrants are rapists
criminals and drug dealers is the guy
that says some interesting things about
women says that women should be punished
for abortion in terms of a trade deal we
should absolutely listen because that is
a brilliant opportunity okay
my dad is a massive remainer he went to
the pupils March so I've definitely seen
both sides me and my dad have completely
conflicting views I think the way that
we can get on and still have a great
relationship even though we completely
disagree on the EU and it's a good
example and I think a lot more remain as
need to learn that kind of Tolerance
yeah well I mean there's intolerance on
both sides you've got some remainders
that call breakfast here is all racist
and stupid you've got rhythm break the
tears who call all remainders traitors
and blah blah blah we need to talk
better with each other
okay go for it
so what do you think since I believe
what do you think they lied about okay
so they said that we could leave the EU
without damaging trade at all by
definition that's just not the case is
okay so in Sunderland there's a factory
that sends 17 percent of its cars to
mainland Europe now if there's a barrier
then seventy percent of their cars are
gonna face an extra cost where would you
put your factory yeah yeah but what
happens to those 35,000 jobs if they
choose to put the factory on the other
side of that barrack you've just pretty
much admitted that it would cause I have
noted that it's just that you said what
would happen to those 35,000 jobs if
they weren't there anymore then
obviously people are gonna be unemployed
that's obvious but but I personally
can't remember a time where they leave
actually said that
[Music]
you know what although we completely
disagree in terms of Freck sir I think
you're a really nice guy and I
definitely like to have another drink
yeah I definitely have you
[Music]